foreign
[Music]
how do you come up with this stuff I
just want people to be more body
positive you know sex isn't shameful
it's beautiful like the noises yeah come
on
[Laughter]
I'm into that [__] too
you guys must be new to town right new
to town but not new to the country we
just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
you want to play Fly
slides off limits to Ching chongs
cute
do you want to be best friends look at
me look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country we used
to talk about it all the time when we're
little remember Grand Adventure to find
your birth mother so proud of you
y'all calling me crazy my translator in
Beijing Audrey I got you ready
[Laughter]
the cat lives there now your famous
college roommate you ready to lose to a
celebrity
Dead Eye is coming by the way get out
your cousin hey Audrey oh hi hey where
did that come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in high
chain okay will you guys come with me
[__] yes [__] I love a grand Adventure
you're drug dealers now [__] what the
[__] is it a condom we can't get caught
with drugs in China we'll get jailed for
life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
we could still find her our passports
are in my suitcase that got stolen you
know we can bypass the airport security
K-pop Stars everyone remember their
names sassy Lisa Lisa too I don't
believe these girls are singles girls
show them
um
throw a fan of cardi B right yeah but is
she here
in this
video are you good did you get the coke
bags out yeah but only seven and I think
I put an eight just push pull I mean
it's not a puppet it's my [__]
[Music]
laughs